دراسه صادمه الملل مفيد للصحه
والسهم الملتهب يسرد لتفاعلكم قصه اللاعب
الاسطوره
ومجددا امريكا تخشى كورونا الصين اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
طيب من اليوم ورايح نصيحه ما عاد تطرده
اذا حسيته حالكم عندكم شعور بالملل اكيد
عم تسالوا حالكم ليش لانه دراسه نشرتها
صحيفه الفرنسيه
كثار احساس قاتل وخطير هو فعليا وبحسب هذه
الدراسه العكس الدراسه بتقول انه شعور
بالملل عنده كثير من الفوائد لاسيهما على
الصحه العقليه للانسان سبحان الله دراسه
الطبيه النفسيه الي عملت في فرنسا
استاندات علشان اللي عاشوا الفرنسيين خلال
فتره العزل الصحي ووقت التزم الكل بيوتهم
الصحيفه الفرنسيه قالت كمان انه الناس
بفتره الحجر استفادوا من كثير اشياء منها
انه اكتر قرروا يرجعوا يقراوا كتبهم او
كتب هن كانوا حابين انهم يقراوها وغيرهم
اختار انه يتعلم لغه جديد الطبيب النفسي
باتريك ليمونا اياه بيشوف انه بس مشعر
احنا بالملل عقلنا لحاله او لوحده راح
يصير وكانه بيطير وراح تنفتح الفجوات ما
بين الدماغ الايمن والايسر ويمكن انه يظهر
وميض العبقريه والله بصراحه انا ملاقيتها
هي خبريه حلوه كثير وعموما الموضوع نكمل
يا جماعه لانه وفقا لاغلب الباحثين في علم
النفس وعلم الاجتماع في فرنسا والولايات
المتحده الملل بيعزز الابداعات تخيلوا
الدليل انه دراسه طبيه نفسيه امريكيه نشرت
عام 2014 اظهرت نفسيا عملت لاربعين شخص
اظهر وابداعات اكثر بعد خدوعهم لاختبارات
ممله جدا جدا
على ما الحمد لله هلا احنا صار عندنا حجه
نقنع حالنا فيها على الاقل لما نكون فعلا
حساسين بالملل ومعنا ايش نعمل ولكن حتى
نفهم اكثر عن هذه الدراسه معنا الان من
عمان
زوم الدكتوره رشا التميمي اخصائيه الطب
النفسي اهلا فيك يا دكتوره رشا معنا في
تفاعلكم يعني هو يقال بانه الحاجه ام
الاختراع ففعلا لما نكون احنا نشعر بالملل
ينطبق هذا المثل مثلا وبالتالي بنصير احنا
بحاجه الى اي نوع من انواع الترفيه حتى لو
ما كان هذا الشيء متوفر لنا من خلال
تليفزيون شاشه التلفزيون او ال- همم
السوشيال ميديا او التليفونات راح همم
نخترع شيء لحتى يرفه عن نفسه
يسعد مساك رايه ويسعد مساء المشاهدين
جميعا اهلا وسهلا اهلا فيك في البدايه هم
يقصد فيهم اكثر مش حاله الملل بوضح انه
شعور
الذي يعني فيه الانسان الضجر هو يقصد فيه
اكثر حاله السكون اللي بيمر فيها العقل
يعني الحاله اللي ما بيكون فيها الانسان
وجسدي من كثر المهام التي يضعها على نفسه
سواء مهام عمليه الها علاقه بالمهنه اولها
علاقه بالاسره ولا علاقه بالارتباطات
الاجتماعيه حاله السكون اللي بمر فيها
العقل هي حاله مطلوبه وفريده منه نوعها
وهي همم يعني يمكن هذا يستغربوا عدد من
المشاهدين هي حاله مطلوبه علاجيه ترتبط في
ما يسمى باليقظه الذهنيه
احنا بنستعد نستخدمه كاخصائيه علاج جد
سلوكي همم من اجل راحه العقل ومن اجل صفاء
وحتى يكون زي ما ذكرتي همم قادر اكثر
قابليه على الانتاج وعلى الابتكار
الموضوع اتعقد كثير بصراحه دكتوره وانا
كنت مبسوطه انه يعني مش لازم احس بالذنب
مثلا اذا اولادي ضلوا يقولوا زهقانين او
احنا نشعر بالملل ضجرانين وانا ما يعني ما
همم عملت لهم اي نوع من انواع الترفيه
يعني فلازم احس بالذنب ولا لا هو هو عدم
فعل شيء هو عمل شيء هو لا تقوم باي عمل هو
انت ذهنيه بتقومي بعمل فعليا انت بتقومي
اما بتامل بتامر
تقومي بممارسه حتى لو شيء بسيط بيديك او
ممارسه التخيل شيء امر سعيد او او ذكرى
سعيده او حتى تخيل شيء همم سوف تقومين
بالمستقبل فهذا مجرد القيام فيه هو بحداته
وعمل ولكنه عمل
بشكل كتير كتير بصفاء الدهن طب دكتور انا
كنت عم تتحدث عن السكون الدهني او السكون
بيحس انه العقل مش
بكتير من يا الواجبات يا اما الخطط يا اما
شو ما كان يكون وهون ممكن انه يكون في
مساحه للابداع طب مش ممكن انه او بعديها
بيكون في مساحه للابداع مش ممكن انه هاي
الفتره تطول فبالتالي ندخل في حاله سكون
فبيصير الملل مضاعف يعني هيك حالك ومش
عارفين نخرج منه
طبعا هلا بدي يكون في محاذير للموضوع انه
انا اقوم بهذا ال- اقوم بهذا النشاط
الدهني او او الاسترخاء ذهني
ليس بقصد اضرار الافكار السلبيه او سمح
الله يعني المشاعر السلبيه او الذكريات
السيئه غالبا بتكون في الماضي او الابحاث
المستقبل بقدر ما هي انه عيش اللحظه ان
نعيشها هنا والان بالعكس هي هي ليست
انفصال عن الواقع هي هي فعليا هي الواقع
ذاته انا اعيش اللحظه كما هي ولكن بدون
همم ارهاق نفسي بانشطه اخرى عيش اللحظه
كما هي يعني انا بنصح كثير من المراجعين
بحكي لهم عيشوا همم وقتك انت مين تايم
يعني خصص وقت لنفسك انت لا باس اذا ما كنت
بتعمل فيه ولا شيء لا باس هذا بحداته شيء
يعني الدراسه عمله في فرنسا
واخدت يعني كمثال اللي صار في وقت كورونا
وهذا الشيء لا ينطبق على فرنسا فقط ولكن
على العالم اجمع كلنا التزمنا ببيوتنا في
فتره الحجر وكلنا اضطرينا انه نلاقي بدائل
همم الروتين اليومي اللي احنا كنا همم
متعودين عليه هل يعني هل كل نقدر نقول انه
البشريه كلها عاده اكتشاف نفسنا وعنها
واكتشاف عائلتها لانه عندنا مع بعض في
البيت في فتره كرونه فبالتالي همم وصلنا
لهذه المرحله من السكون فعلا
ما هي عدد كبير من الاشخاص يعني حتى
الكورنه حملت معها سلبيات صحيه وسلبيات
اقتصاديه لا شك هذا الامر ولكن حملت معها
ايضا كثير من الايجابيات الكثير اعدد
اكتشاف نفسه عاد اكتشاف صفاته
وزاد وعيه لنفسه ما يحب ما يكره لانه كان
فعليا في العمليه المهنيه الاجتماعيه بدون
ان يضع نفسه اولا حتى نفسه ما هي بحاجه له
وتم اكتشاف كمان الزوج لزوجته والزوجه
لزوجها على بعض بهاي الفتره ولقينا شغالين
شكرا جزيلا لك يا دكتوره رشا التميمي
اخصائيه الطب النفسي شكرا
اهلا فيكم من جديد ما في احلى من انه يجي
يوم ويتكلم فيه الانسان على اشياء عملها
بالحياه وخصوصا اذا كانت هل اعمال مميزه
وصنعت التاريخ لا ينسى بس كيف اذا كانت
تكريم كمان ضمن فعاليات موسم الرياض هذا
اللي صار العميد لاعبي العالم صاحب
المسيره الرياضيه الخارج عن المقلوب في
الطبيعه طبعا واللي بيعجز اللسان عن وصفه
كتير كتير حكت عن مسيرته وظل لاكثر من
عقدين عم يصنع المعنى الحقيقي للاعجاز
الكروي من غيره لايقونه عبد الله فاكرين
مسجد عبد الله كان في مسرحيه السهم
الملتهب اللي كانت ضمن الموسم الرياضي
وجاءت كالغيث الى جسد رحله الاسطوره لكن
قبل ما ندخل بتفاصيل مسرحيه خلونا
مشاهدينا نسترجع سواء اجمل الاهداف اللي
حققها ماجد عبد الله بن مسيرته الرياضيه
الحافيه
يوسف خميس
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اهداف ماجد عدى من المدافع واغطى على يسار
حارس المرمى يا حبيبي يا ماجد يا سلام يا
ماجد شوف
الهدنه هذا ماجد عبد الله هذا ماجد عبد
الله شوف عدى عدى
من بكره
مركز عبدالله
[ضحك]
[تصفيق]
هدفاته اول كوره يستلمها لعبه سريعه
وطويله في اتجاه ماجد عبدالله ماجد باجري
ومعها ايمن الحسيني
ارضيه المهله
[تصفيق]
شايفين ماجد انطلقوا وعمل نفس الاسلوب ما
هو على المكيني ويلاعبها وهو منطلق الى
قلب المرمى الكويتي يعلن تاهل المنتخب
السعودي
وحقته بتمثيل المجموعه الخامسه في
التصفيات النهائيه لاسيا عن همم بطوله كاس
العالم الف مبروك لمنتخبنا الف مبروك
لكرتنا ماجد شايفين دخل بها
على الحارس
عموما المسرحيه اللي انتهى عرضها مؤخرا
كانت روعه بشاهده الجمهور الحاضر واستعرضت
ابرز محطات ماجد عبد الله اللي قام بتاديه
دوره الممثل السعودي فيصل الدوخي اللي قال
في تصريحات للعربيه انه الدور كان من اصعب
الادوار في حياته وينها تحضيرات العرض
بدات قبل بشهر دوخي ما اكتفى بنص المسرح
وراح ابعد واستعان بالمواد المتاحه على
الانترنت حتى يتعرف على طباعه وابعاد ماجد
الشخصيه اكثر وهذا يا جماعه بحداته خير
دليل على قديش شخصيه الاسطوره ماجد عبد
الله فريده دوخي كشف للعربيه ناس كمان عن
اتصالات مع ماجد واللي كانت بتدور حول
طريقه تصرفه مع عائلته مع اصدقائه واكثر
من هيك كمان الدوخي ركز خلال الاجتماع مع
اللاعب على سلوكيات وتحركاته الجسديه ورده
فعله وقال انه وجع تحدي كبير بكيفيه نقل
الهدوء ماجد للمسرح واصاله للجمهور
طبعا انا هلا مش عارفه كيف راح اقدم ضيفي
هل اقول مثلا هو السهم الملتهب اللي هو
طبعا مسجد عبد الله او ممثل السهم الملتهب
الفنان السعودي فيصل الدوخي راح اترك
الاجابه له قبل ما ابدا طبعا اسئله كثيره
اهلا وسهلا فيك
عبد الله كان على المسرح يعني
كيف كانت تجربتك في اداءها انت ذكرت بانه
كانت من اصعب الادوار اللي اديتها هل بيبي
بداياتها كان كنت تعتبرها على على الاقل
حتى لو بداخلك لانه كانت مغامره كبيره همم
يعني في هذه المرحله من مسيرتك
والله فعلا هي مغامره طبعا هي بدات فكره
المسرحيه هي جاءت من معالي المستشاره
التركيه ال الشيخ
واعلن عنها في الاعلام يعني السنه اللي
فاتت اعتقد او بدايه او بدايه 22 وانا
سمعت الاعلان كان في برنامج رياضي كان
موجود مع المستشار وكان على يمين الكابتن
يوسف الثنيان وقال ان في الربع الاول من
23 راح يكون في مسرحيه للكابتن يوسف
ومسرحيه الكابتن ماجد عبد الله همم بس ما
شاء الله يعني معالي دائما همم في كل شيء
سريع والانجاز عند قبل موعد همم
المقرر يعني فهنا في الربع الرابع من 22
والمسائيتين متنفذه الحمد لله فكلمني
المنتج بشكل رسمي انه حب يشارك وهمم شاركت
معهم الفكره كانت في الاساس اني انا راح
ادي دور ماجد عبد الله في فتره الشباب فقط
ولكن لما جينا اول يوم قراءه الطاوله وكذا
لقينا المفترض انه يلعب دور كبير ولازم
شخص ثاني يلعب دور ماجد عبد الله الشاب
والعمل الممثل عبد الرحمن المزين بحكم
التغييرات والتبديل في الميك اب والهم
والملابس ما في تايم تلازم ممثلين
وكانت صعبه بالنسبه لي اني اخذ شخصيه ماجد
عبد الله الفتره الحاليه ولكن يوم رحت
وجلست معه وتكلمت معها همم بديت وهو كان
سهل للموضوع كان يقول لي لا تفكر باي شيء
اهم شيء قد كويس ولا تفكر في اي شيء لا
تفكر بشكل لا تفكر ماشي لا تفكر بس انا
حاربت ان احنا نروح ونقرب نسبه 60 70%
بالفعل يدرس هذا الدور من كل الجوانبه
هذه الدراسه من المعلم الاصلي يعني صاحب
الشخصيه الاصليه ولكن انا سمعت انك يعني
شويه تعبته
اتصالات كثير واجتماعات كثير واسئله
وتفاصيل كثير يعني ان شاء الله بنكون
تعبته كثير
انا متاح يعني ما قصروا وقف معنا الكابتن
ماجد سواء انا او ماجد الشاب او ماجد
الصغير والمخرج ايضا كنا نرجع لها باشياء
كثيره ولكن ما قصر معنا باي شيء وانا
حاولت اني ما ازعجتك كثير همم واكثر شيء
بدري في ايام العروض كان موجود يوميا يحضر
وكان حريص ان بعد العرض يجينا ويقول ترى
انت قلت كده والصح انك تسوي كذا ثاني
اعطيني تنبيهات يوميا يعني
ملاحظات يعني على الاداء حتى تتحسن يعني
على همم كل يوم
بالضبط هذا اللي سواه الكابتن ماجد وهو
يسوي كبش التمثيل معي المفروض فهو اللي
سواء الكابتن ماجد كان يجي يقول لي ترى
كذا المعلومه هذه لازم تنقل بالطريقه هذه
مش بس الكابتن ماجد
[موسيقى]
اكتر عن ردود الفعل بعد عرض المسرحيه يعني
الحقيقه شوهد لها بانها كانت جميله جدا من
الحاضرين انت كيف كيف وجدت تقبل الجمهور
للمسرحيه وخصوصا انه المسرح يعني مش مش
سهل همم
وصوله للمتلقي مثل التلفزيون ومثل همم
السينما خصوصا لا شخصيات مثل شخصيات ماجد
عبدالله
الفريق الافراج بقياده نهايه البقمي
وفريق الممثلين كلهم يعني حاولوا يقدموا
ممكن يقدر عليه احنا اول عرض كان عندنا
كلنا خائفين منها لان الكابتن ماجد موجود
اسرته موجوده
فعلهم هم قبل الجمهور
وكانوا مبسوطين الحمد لله هذا اعطانا ثقه
ان احنا نروح بشكل اطول جماهير بالعروض
التاليه رده فعل الجمهور جدا رائعه الناس
بعد العرض قاعدين يثنون على العرض بشكل
كبير وهذا الحمد لله بفضل الله همم لما
نوقفناها رساله كثير جاءتني زعلانين يعني
كان اخر عرض هو امس قبل امس فكانوا
زعلانين ناس يرسلوا لي ان احنا نبغى نجي
واحنا ما امدانا وما حصلنا تكت بس ان شاء
الله اكيد في خطه في الموسم او همم نهايه
عادي يعني بتتكرر على الرجال
طيب يعني حبيت هيك سؤال فضولي اعرف انو
افضل او اجمل الاهداف برايك يعني
للكابتن ماجد عبدالله
المنتخب الصيني همم
واذا كان السؤال على اجمل هدف
اذا اذا
متاكد من التاريخ
84 كامله
ايه لانه يمكننا نصراوي هو
في مباراه كانت تعتقد مع احد جاب هدف ولكن
الهدف جاء من برا
الشابوه هدف
وماجد عبد الله اعترف قال ترى مو هدف يا
جماعه راح الحكم قال له تراني ما جبته
يعني اقدر اجيب هدف حقيقي
هلالي او على الاقل يمكن عشان ولدك عبد
الله الهلال
انا انا ماني مشجع انا مالي في الكوره
يعني يمكن تقريبا من ثمانيه الى 10 سنوات
ولكن عندي ابني عبدالله وبنت عائشه يحبون
الهلال فانا عشانهم قالوا لي لازم تشجع
هلا قلت انا هلالي عشانكم فمتى ما غيرهم
يقول لهم انا باغير
العائله كلها تتمتع بروح رياضيه
فكانوا مبسوطين بهذه الاسطوره
وفخر لك همم لكل همم الجمهور السعودي يعني
اكيد شكرا جزيلا لكم نتمنى لك كل التوفيق
وبنتمنى انك تمدد المسرحيه حتى يتسنى
المزيد من همم طبعا الناس انه يحضروها
ويشوفوا هالمسيره الجميله الرائعه طبعا
همم الاسطوره ماجد عبد الله شكرا جزيلا لك
الفنان السعودي فيصل الدوخي
طيب الان من الفن للصحه وتحديدا لكرونه
اللي ما عم تعرف الصين بصراحه بترتاح منه
الظاهر انه راح يرجع ياثر عليها
شقوق كثير كانت عم بتدور حول اذا كانت
البدايات اللي عم بت عم بتقدمها الصين او
البيانات اللي عم بتقدمها الصين حول
الاصابات هي صحيحه ام لا والموضوع شكل
مخاوف عندي كثير من دول العالم الولايات
المتحده اللي قالت انها عم تدرس فرض
اجراءات جديده متعلقه بكرونه على الوافدين
من الصين
عموما مش بس الولايات المتحده اتجهت نحو
هذه الخطوه اليابان والهند وماليزيا كمان
اعلنت تكثيف القواعد الوافدين من الصين
وسبب اكيد طبعا زياده الاصابات بفارس
كورونا هناك البيان او عفوا اليابان قالت
انها راح تطلب من الوافدين تقديم فحص سلبي
للفايروس بي وقت فرضت ماليزيا اجراءات
اكثر للرصد والمتابعه بس يا جماعه الموضوع
بالصين مش بهذه السهوله اكيد في
المستشفيات هناك ودور الجنازات بالفعل عم
بتواجه ضغوطات كبيره بسبب زياده انتشار
الفايروس وكمان ما بدنا ننسى انه الصحف
الاجنبيه حكت من الاسبوع او من حوالي
اسبوع عن نقص الكبير اللي صاير بالدواء
بسبب كثره الطلب عليه فالموضوع عن جد ممكن
انه يشكل خطر على الصين
اغنيه مشاهدينا وصلنا الى ختام هذه الحلقه
من تفاعلكم اشكلكم حسن متابعه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]